this week we got bellybutton
salty scent and two mommies two mommies
why are you surprised there's so many -
wassup no I just like I wish I had two
mommies do you really you really want
two of your mom oh I don't think he
knows what he's I wish I do mommy said
like kissing each other oh yeah yeah
buddy it'll be your mommy doesn't it be
your mom you freak okay good point
but a very popular porn right now yeah
really worth scoping out worth checking
up in Joe say like it says porn is like
the [ __ ] right now
yeah it's gigantic so if you look at
porn right now it's gonna be a bunch of
incest porn just go to pornhub and those
are like the main things why that's
always the worst when your favorite
adult film star is in a thing and then
she's like she's like oh you're my
brother and it's like well there's so
many I want we got that's why you just
have to click on it and just not read
the title cuz then how would you know
but yeah but then they don't but then it
surprises you there's a dialogue dude
mute it I'm like I want to hear you oh
that's a good point
girls don't like hearing it cuz I should
so fake but I think that's what the part
that guy girls don't make that noise but
we've got like barely touching her oh my
god oh my god what we want to believe
that's the thing about it though it's
like when I had a girlfriend minimal
work that will get her off the milk well
no it's because we get easily tricked I
remember when I was in high school I
thought like on different days I was
like wheat my girlfriend has big boobs
and I was like we know she doesn't cuz
she would wear bras or different like
whatever and then I'd like oh she does
have big boobs and then I'd be like oh
wait no she doesn't like I would get
easily tricked because guys like that
guys are easily but you forget within
like the week right I mean how old do
you go I was 25
if that sounds like some you it still
happens to guys I'm Tanya they're still
just still like that the sports broad no
sports bra but because guys oh yeah I
remember like there's that uh jenna
Marbles be a long time ago oh yeah yeah
which is I look I look I'm on the swim
team or like Ski Team or some [ __ ] like
that
and that's because she's run a sport and
it's because guys want to believe we are
always half full kind of guys and we
want and we think the cup is half full
the bracha yeah we want it to be for our
first story this woman she's 23 years
old from Jalisco Mexico that's where
you're from my family that's the state
yeah mine and yours dude yes sir you as
a friend I knew that yeah so her name is
paulina paulina yeah paulina and so she
is a body modification phonetic and back
in 2015 she you decided to remove her
bellybutton holy [ __ ] you could do that
she's trying to do humanize herself
Wow because it that's what makes us
human and so she then what other things
we're not not the only thing yet okay so
then she then gave it as a present to
her then-boyfriend oh not together
anymore
he still has her belly button so she had
like an Audi or some bise's she has nice
lips she got rid of it it looks like
it's old I can still look I don't get it
what was it before and then I don't know
before I still see a belly button
yeah Sam's yes this is a really wooden
groan it's so starry and what why
because she wanted to dehumanize herself
she wanted to remove anything that like
associated will start walking on all
fours then [ __ ] no because I'm also
like she had a lot of issues with her
family but why give it as a gift because
she wanted to give it as a gift I'm what
she should have done is swap her but
hold on her bellybutton
way less human that's way less she could
have got somebody other besides a three
year old to do her tattoos might have
helped out yeah so she also has a back
course that they mentioned I don't know
what is that like piercings yeah and
then like
yeah what if she [ __ ] gets caught in
a turnstile good if I was her friend I
would just literally put magnets on her
all the time just like on every single
one oh that's not a friend good friend
let's go to the turnstiles next to a
really big magnet I get a we get a
padlock and then put it that's so
interesting to me how people modify
their bodies like there's other ones
where they put like balls in their skull
dude the earrings ones is always pretty
nuts where they have those like stretch
it the cages yeah the gauges go gates
their nose though gauge they're like the
Wonder hear anything though cage
anything that they can what is what it's
what the gauging thing it's just body
modification people just they're like
it's my body I can do what I want well I
saw this cat who had who had no gauges
in there anymore so it was just like
like the loose skin just flapping around
there's nuts looking like it's the only
thing I could look at the whole time I
saw the guy he's pretty distracting yeah
yeah some people just really like they
see their body as this canvas that they
just want to change but we don't tattoo
their eyeballs I know I've seen I've
seen some of those I'm just too busy for
any of it [ __ ] yeah any of it but I
think that it's pretty badass that they
do all this [ __ ] yeah or they'll split
their tongue with tattoos account is
body modification yes yeah cuz you're
modifying your body you're modifying
your skin because I only think of it
like that like when it's like crazy
yeah dude sleeves look good on some
people I'm like you look way better with
sleeves
yeah only on some people on some people
yeah and some people it looks pretty
pretty just right now no I don't think
it looks good on bark it's gotta be yeah
I have anywhere near never no I'm saying
there's a person right there Leslie
remember I have a sleeve that's the
crazy thing to like you've had tattoos I
forget you have tattoos me too I
remember
I forget you have a tattoo to take over
play with them yeah well he looks at it
sometimes like pointing my don't touch
my body modifications [ __ ] well yes and
now Polina saying that she regrets it
because she said it was impulsive so she
wants it back she was reckless and that
she hurt not the reason she regrets the
reason why she did it
because she was trying to remove herself
from her family like just trying to like
oh but you know how you do that you
remove yourself from your family you
don't stay in the family to remove your
belly button she comes home and she's
like yeah like you [ __ ] this is my
first mouth it's gone my mom goes okay
I'll take his car away she's like ah
[ __ ] exactly mom's like it's 8:30 you
get your ass in bed she's like yeah I
don't do that now though yeah
yes sir paulina said even though I did
it for the wrong reasons it has now
taught me I should think things through
acting and it's a nice reminder that
characterizes me at least she didn't
like take her boobs off or something
that's all belly button you can get
around that yeah because it still looks
like she has all he looks like yeah what
do you mean shouldn't take her boobs off
though no at least she didn't do
something she would attach you over and
she just cut it off and there's no
nipples no nothing it would have been
crazier she like took out all her teeth
and removed her eyeballs that for me
would be like removed I don't know man
herself removing the coolest thing yet
intentions like no boobs do what I'm
just picturing like I'm out in the
notebook and like no boobs yeah there's
some people that don't give a [ __ ] about
yeah but they're doing it they don't do
it they don't do it to go I'm out mom
right it's the intention and in the
action that spared the intention doesn't
make sense right that's right yeah yeah
I get that I'm on you I'm on your team
I'm just saying that her removing their
booze isn't that crazy that's all my
button is crazier all right
are you fifty Cent recently Oh decided
to troll ja rule because you know
they've been having this like twenty why
ja Rule relevant though I know he is
he's like saving your career job role
you better thank him for sure this and
it's a group on to draw rule body dude
he's a funny [ __ ] so he loves me
get and he commented think I mean so go
see this fifteen bucks
wait what do I do now lol and then he
commented I just bought 200 seats in the
front so they can be that's good that's
that [ __ ] you would do if you got five
would I would you're exactly right
what he said was what a show I mean just
[ __ ] great do it again my kid went to
the restroom lol that is [ __ ]
spiteful [ __ ] how many seats 200 helps
ja rule it does that's cool yeah he did
not say that I'm sure he's performing
and he's [ __ ] sad a little bit oh yeah
John Russell's like my mood in front but
it's it's the consumer perception though
really it doesn't matter cuz everybody
just moved to the front move to the
front move move to the front yeah and
the kid they can't wait I know but if I
went to the shots we'd be like oh yeah I
would feel bad I show up and it's all em
kid they're like oh damn that's [ __ ]
sad and then he goes well this is not oh
not because 50 cent already put it out
so everybody knows or maybe because Ja
Rule's older now people don't want to
sit that much closer cuz he looks older
actually it's like maybe if you sit far
but he knows the joke so all he has to
do is move the front I got paid well
what I do
Oh John rule tweeted this bit beef is a
joke to everyone except this little
ape-looking [ __ ] she mad mad that's
[ __ ] funny that's a good shot I think
I believe that job will probably did
that himself
yeah I got you picked one that's like
him to the side that's actually really
good
that's pretty funny then and it's only
appropriate that another black man calls
another black indeed all right - that's
always interesting how do you guys feel
if this escalates like gunshots
stabbing already Oh a dude who got
stabbed 50 from Ja Rule's camp wasn't he
stabbed like a thousand times or
something yeah so I think back in the
day a young buck stabbed one of someone
in Ja Rule's crew crew on stage cool
that's tight rules clearly well then I
mentioned young buck in this breakdown
of their 20-year beef they don't know
that [ __ ] history that yeah yeah so in
this breakdown here they're saying that
they got into a fight in Atlanta and and
then that's where where they were both
booked to perform and then both both of
their neck chains were broken and then
50 claims that there was a deal that was
made to return it in exchange for a
watch a band job deny that baby
escalated from there it's like next week
he's gonna TP the guy so that was great
that was first and then in March of 2000
that's when John his crew decided to pay
a visit to city and then that's when
they got into an altercation and city
suffered a stab wound and then ja rule
and this other rapper named black child
they were both arrested a black child
took the credit for the stabbing and he
was saying that was in self-defense
but then in interviews city says he just
downplays the incident it's so
interesting I wonder if I gave 150 says
drinks water just water comes out
everywhere now
yeah
like a [ __ ] like water pot before our
planet [ __ ] just [ __ ] him everywhere man
this guy has so many holes in his body
now ja Rule can't take he can't burn
back his heart either cuz like that's
pretty funny like buying 200 seats and
then just to get with the Photoshop
where he looks kind of like Janet Reno
or whatever it's like guys it's okay you
know I mean it's not great it's like all
right but then what so that's why I feel
like if 50 tp'ed the guys house ja Rule
would him back and be like thanks for
the free toilet paper bro it's like
dance I think the only way he would have
been able to get him back because if he
did something so juvenile it was stupid
like he's [ __ ] in front of his door yeah
yeah exactly
bag of [ __ ] on fire like [ __ ] in front
of his door and then just Photoshop it
these face off I know because I feel
like 50 is getting them pretty good and
then Ja Rule's like what I stole your
mail get to that point they're just like
doing like pranks yeah cuz they're
getting older so it's like the entire
guys but I guess just taking like the
high road here at least for now cuz he
was like yeah I get under fifty cents
skin I love it
it's true though he does get under his
skin and for me it's like dude ja Rule
is so irrelevant now like I don't even
use in that word but he really is and
you're a bajillion err so what's the
point
like it just it's making him more money
if if G's a vagina yeah that's awesome
ridiculously rich it's like it's making
ja Rule board money it's making more
relevant and then it's making you look
petty so what was the point of this it's
like for this it makes him look funny
for the bed for the shits and giggles it
makes him look funny I like him a little
bit more now that he did that it's
funnier than how I read I just wouldn't
if I really hate ism buddy I wouldn't
put more money in the pocket yeah it's
weird when you're 50 cent and you're up
here and like you've had like [ __ ] to
to shooting video games made about you
yeah you wanna mean and then it's like
ja Rule it's like dude like he's wet
he's so far down there you know it's
like bow would you give it was sometimes
also fun to be paid you pettiness that's
what it is yeah petty wah all right for
our last story for the first time ever
there was a baby that was born that was
carried by both of his mothers
yeah this baby was carried by both
mothers so it's like hey I do three
months you do three months was it cuz
they retracted the egg from one mama and
then the other mama was like the
surrogate or did they scissor each other
the baby swam through the vagina oh
sorry about that yeah well one up that
so that's already a common thing where
people use like in the same sex couple
two females like one will use the egg
and the other one carries been a thing
okay so the new thing here is effortless
IVF and it's a cheaper way of doing the
traditional IVF which is in vitro
fertilization and I'm gonna play this
video and they'll explain how it happens
this is stats Elaine Coulter yes
Colt recalled their miracle baby hook
you that mr. Stetson came into this
world was pretty special
through effortless IVF instead of
placing the sperm and eggs in treadmill
debaters they go into an invis cell this
cuz i'm vasilis in the body for five
days where fertilization occurs an early
embryo development begins when he doing
in the Coulter's case after five days
bliss have the info cell removed the
embryos were frozen and then one was
transferred to ashley she carried the
baby to term so the difference here is
in traditional ivf without that in both
cell device the fetus is created or what
does it call the embryo it's created in
an incubator but instead of that
incubator they put it in that device and
then the one that put in the mommy she
and given her uterus for five days and
then they take it out and they
inseminate it into so still not
fifty-fifty it's not fifty-six like
ninety nine one for sure because the
first one she was never actually
pregnant yeah it's only one of them that
was pregnant
all they played us for headlines man
yeah man but they both carried the baby
yeah technically technically I mean
that's like me saying I technically
carried Tyco cuz he was living in my
ball sack for a little bit
no because it's not the full yeah not
the full time well like one arm one leg
was living in my ballsack literally
[ __ ] what I said ha yeah you like
less than half lit up
look let him explain himself all right
but my our situation is more fair than
theirs because mine's actually 50 feet
is it does not know I want ya that's not
no it is that's not as fair because one
of the eggs was from the first one
something a group project we're suppose
my good man put my name on it
teiecast stage right now - because he's
so like explorative yeah it's very
cognizant so I was at you guys his house
and then he was playing with the little
like the little musical thing yeah and
then I was putting in I was tapping on
it and then he would look at it and he
would tap on he was look at me he goes
do another what he taps on it looks at
me cuz he's like looking for a response
you know I'm like learning and [ __ ] and
I'm putting it to other things he's I'm
tapping on again he taps on and he looks
at me and smiles should I figure out
what the [ __ ] I'm so cool dude
those are his smart moments there's
other moments you give him a xylophone
and he pulls off his dick in his mouth
[Laughter]
pulling off the xylophone yeah he pulled
the notes that was that was the whole
time at his birthday saying he's just
trying to kill himself the whole time
those kids he's like running towards the
pool just to Jay it's like nope nope no
inverse is like every time he tries that
he picked something off the ground to
eat it nope nope nope like the whole
[ __ ] love it it's so funny
yeah that spend the whole time doing
that mmm can't wait to have them I don't
know man we just actually talked to
Danielle we just talked to Anna
Christina actually on a podcast about
this where it was like should we [ __ ]
I even have kids at all and aunt kind of
week winked me little bit what does that
mean
well he's kind of like totally hey bro
it's it's great you know what I mean
where I'm like oh that wanted it like
never more yeah before I know before
but I think you know he's got
it's a lot of responsibility I think
like if they're like not mentally
prepared for it then it's gonna be [ __ ]
in the beginning dude I asked them out
straight up I was like do you guys have
free time anymore and they're like oh
god like a scene from get out yeah
exactly
yeah we did but it's still great every
time look at her so rate okay but you
don't have any free time that's big for
me but like having having me time a kid
you'll never have free time because
you're taking care of this kid yeah
depends on how good of a parent you are
if you want to be a ship here and then
yeah yeah if you want to be a TV parent
I can be a TV pair yeah I think I have a
bunch of free time I can be me yeah yeah
[Music]